Комфортні трамваї з Цюриха, місткі турецькі автобуси, тролейбуси власного виробництва і лише вряди-годи приватні маршрутки -
такий транспорт нині можна зустріти на вулицях Вінниці. Однак так було не завжди.
До реформи транспортної системи міста у 2012-му пасажирів тут перевозили майже 600 маршруток.
Їхні власники, за деякими оцінками, заробляли 1,5 мільйона доларів на рік і могли диктувати місту свої умови.
Випуск трамваїв потихеньку падав, тролейбусів - падав, автобусів не було.
І була поставлена задача міським головою, на той час Володимиром Борисовичем Гройсманом, зробити підготовчий період.
І ми розпочали цю роботу. До кінця року була розроблена нова модель маршрутної мережі в місті Вінниці.
А наше підприємство ще десь за пів року до того розпочало підготовку рухомого складу.
Це трамваї, тролейбуси для того, щоб можна було вакуум від того, що підуть марштрутні таксі, нам заповнити. І Вінниця буде працювати.
За останні 9 років Вінниця значно наростила кількість муніципального транспорту.
Ремонтували вже наявний, випускали трамваї власного виробництва та регулярно купували нові одиниці.
Тепер вулицями міста щоденно курсують 67 автобусів, 133 тролейбуси та 74 трамваї.
Муніципальний транспорт здійснює 80% усіх перевезень у Вінниці.
Приватні ж перевізники обслуговують лише п’яту частину пасажирів.
Перше завдання, яке було, це надати пріоритет громадському транспорту і, відповідно,
маршрутні таксі повинні були здійснити підвезення пасажирів до вузлових пунктів, де є вже трамвай, тролейбус.
Така ситуація, як у Вінниці, - радше виняток для українських міст.
Здебільшого основну частину перевезень в населених пунктах забезпечують маршрутки, часто старі й небезпечні.
Але на початаку року Міністерство інфраструктури України оголосило їм війну.
У відомстві хочуть прибрати з вулиць звичні для українців "богдани" й "газелі", натомість пустити зручні автобуси й електротранспорт.
За задумом відомства, міста повинні купувати у перевізників транспортну послугу через систему ProZorro.
При цьому до рухомого складу будуть високі вимоги. Як мінімум - низька підлога для доступу маломобільних груп населення.
Тобто, аби продовжити працювати після ухвалення урядового законопроєкту, більшості приватних перевізників доведеться купувати новий транспорт.
Олександр Гота, який у маршрутному бізнесі Вінниці з 1997 року, переконаний: у нинішніх реаліях зробити це буде вкрай складно.
Я спілкуюся, і люди дуже незадововлені. Вони це сприймають з жахом, зі страхом, з недовірою.
Немає у людей, у перевізників, коштів для того, щоб це купити. Взяти кредит? Ви подивіться, який зараз високий відсоток.
При таких ставках і при таких цінах на проїзд людина не зможе виплатити цей кредит.
Вона просто збанкрутує. А цей автобус згниє десь під огорожею.
Тому це нереально, мені здається, треба підняти добробут нашого населення.
Тоді пасажир зможе заплатити 5 євро чи доларів. І він комфортно їздитиме, а ми будемо купувати ці автобуси.
Серед вимог нового законопроєкту - повна відмова від обігу готівки в транспорті.
У кожному автобусі має бути встановлений валідатор для електронної сплати за проїзд.
Це теж може стати перепоною на шляху реалізації реформи.
Вінниці знадобилося майже 3 роки і 5,5 мільйонів євро на те, щоб встановити необхідне обладнання
в усьому муніципальному та частині приватного транспорту.
Ще на початку проекту, коли ми розробляли технічну документацію, ми одразу планували, що приватні перевізники також приєднаються до системи.
Насправді ми впроваджуємо дві системи. Перша система – це автоматизована оплата проїзду, облік оплати.
І друга система – це місцезнаходження транспортних засобів. Ми бачимо табло, є інформаційний центр, є табло на зупинках, які зараз встановлюються.
І громадяни не тільки можуть безготівково оплатити проїзди, а ще й відслідковувати рух транспорту в режимі онлайн.
Наразі валідатори встановлені лише у ста з 240 маршруток у Вінниці.
Решту планують обладнати ними до травня 2021 року.
У майбутньому це повинні будуть зробити усі приватні перевізники України.
Урядовий законопроєкт передбачає, що гроші, сплачені пасажиром за проїзд у маршрутці, одразу потраплятимуть на рахунки місцевої влади.
Та, своєю чергою, розраховуватиметься з перевізниками за кількість кілометрів, які вони проїхали на маршруті.
Очікується, що електронні квитки могли б вивести з тіні мільйони гривень готівки в маршрутному бізнесі.
Однак перевізники не поспішають на це погоджуватися.
Ми хочемо надавати гарні послуги нашим людям.
Але от зараз поставимо валідатори, і, звичайно, буде служба, якій треба буде платити за її послуги.
Ці гроші доведеться знімати з рахунікв, це ще видатки додаткові.
Збільшиться оплата податків у нас. Звичайно, це все тягне за собою певні видатки.
І нам доведеться додати їх до ціни перевезень.
У Вінницькій мерії запевняють, нинішня транспортна система цілком збалансована.
Якість надання послуг маршрутниками тут контролюють, а от цілковито відмовлятися від приватних перевезень поки не планують та й не можуть.
Адже муніципальний транспорт і так збитковий, особливо в умовах обмежень, пов’язаних з пандемією.
А на заміну "богданам" і "спрінтерам" треба було б придбати щонайменше 70 автобусів.
Ціна на кожен - від мільйона гривень. Таких грошей у бюджеті наразі немає.
До того ж, з 1 січня до Вінницької ОТГ приєдналися ще три райони.
Тепер їх треба сполучити з містом. Аби туди поїхав муніципальний електротранспорт, потрібна дорога інфраструктура.
Тож на виручку знову приходять приватні перевізники.
Думки вінничан щодо ініціативи Мінінфраструктури викорінити старі маршрутки розділилися.
Було б непогано, бо вони вже розвалюються ці маршрутки. На них дуже небезпечно їздити і пересуватися. У нас не маршрутки, а катастрофа.
Якщо для цього треба буде на якийсь час вилучати старі маршрутки і, як у нас часто буває, ще рік вводити нові,
багато людей постраждає як пасажири, бо не зможуть добиратися до місць своєї роботи.
Тому що зручно, не завжди транспорт є, нема - тут під’їхав. І якщо людина поспішає кудись, то дуже зручно під’їхати.
Я проти, в розумних межах, скажімо так, щоб і міський транспорт був, і альтернатива. Я за альтернативу.
Нашим трамваям альтернативи не треба і так тролейбусам, які у нас роблять, теж не треба альтернативи.
Ми за те, але щоб були такі як автобуси тепер сучасні, то, звичайно, краще, ніж оці маленькі бусики.
Ескперти також застерігають, що зовсім відмовлятися від послуг приватних перевізників не варто,
адже відсутність конкуренції може погано вплинути на муніципальний транспорт.
Водночас, якщо нічого не змінювати, то за 5-10 років громадський транспорт може остаточно деградувати.
Сама філософія транспортної послуги, тобто перехід від конкурсів на купівлю транспортної послуги - це, безумовно, революція,
вона, безумовно, змінить все у нашому громадському транспорті, але треба почати працювати уже зараз.
Тобто будь-якому місту, яке хоче почати завтра купувати транспортну роботу, потрібно сьогодні подбати про те,
щоб прогнозувати транспортну роботу, про оптимальну мережу громадського транспорту, порахувати бюджет,
скільки місту потрібно грошей, подумати над тарифної політикою і наскільки це люди сприймуть.
Окрім підвищення комфорту в транспорті, пасажирам треба бути готовими і до подорожчання проїзду та до оптимізації й скорочення маршрутів.
У майбутньому нормою можуть стати пересадки в наземному транспорті.
Угода про асоціацію з ЄС передбачає, що реформа громадського транспорту відбудеться вже до 2022 року.
Однак за прогнозами експертів, на повне перезавантаження системи може піти 5 років.
І це за умови, що всі сторони - від депутатів до власників маршруток - порозуміються.